Hey,
what's going on is bill burn?
It's time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday, uh,
February 5th,
2018 what's going and on how,
how are you doing?
I'm actually doing pretty
good after a super bowl loss.
Congratulations to the Philadelphia
Eagles winning their first super bowl
championship. Bobo. The first one,
the first one's the best one.
Um,
if my team hadn't lost,
I would have gone online or something
like that just to watch grown men crying
in Philadelphia over sports,
which is one of my favorite things ever.
Um,
I remember when the Patriots won their
first one. I was actually at the game,
haven't gone previously to when we
lost to fucking bread five Bruh.
He took off his helmet
and ran down the field.
I bet it's age and cried on that play.
We're going to make so much money.
Look at him. He's so adorable. Um,
have you seen a picture of his Dick
Lately? No. Um, I just remember when we
kicked that field goal and we won and
I've got to say we, by the way, people go,
oh, real. You will know
the field. Yeah. Well,
I get shit when my team loses. All
right. Whenever your team wins,
people go, um, you weren't
playing, but if your team loses,
then they got, fuck you guys.
You guys lost. So suck a dick.
All right. We lost just
today. Anyways. Um, yeah,
I remember when we kicked a field goal
to win the fucking thing and everybody,
everybody tackled each other.
And I got up,
there was this guy just standing there
was just standing like tears in his eyes.
Like he was going to fucking start crying
and my eyes met his and he was looking
at me. It's so weird. To this day,
it's still weirdest moment that
I've had with another male.
I could see if we were at a fucking
funeral of Jesus Christ, you know, man,
the fuck up. And I also remember,
um, if I was in Philadelphia,
I would want to hear from that guy.
One of my favorite things this year
in the football season was when
dad got,
and Carson Wentz went down
and that Eagle's fan called
in the radio station and
started breaking down crying to the
point he freaked out. The radio host,
he called up, he was like
sorta complaining that all
of a sudden he's just like,
when's it going to happen for us?
No
can radios is going like buddy,
buddy, you're crying for hours.
It was great.
It was just fucking great.
So I would love to hear that guys followup
call, he's probably crying even more.
So
I really wish when I finally saw the
eagles win the Superbowl that they weren't
playing my team so I could have
enjoyed it more because is something
as a sports fan that I really enjoy
because there's only a two two fan bases
that I just wish,
wish eternal misery on.
And that's the Yankees because I have
to the same way they do it with red sox
fans and the Montreal Canadiens. Other
than that, you know, if I, you know,
I wouldn't ever wished that,
you know,
a fan base never got to
feel a championship. So
congratulations to you guys.
All right. Now, having said that,
um,
I've had the,
that Don Henley song in my head this
whole morning just thinking about the game
because there's always that fucking
devastating shock when your team loses.
And the song I woke up hearing today for
whatever reason was don Henley's last
worthless evening and I was walking
around the kitchen, I was just singing.
That was the worst FARC and d
fence that I've ever seen to,
that was the, you know, it was an exciting
game. But if you really look at it,
that was arguably the ugliest
fucking Superbowl I've ever seen.
It was like both teams were
in a fucking prevent defense.
The entire game that was a
fucking Superbowl people.
There was two punts the
entire game and no sacks,
unless you called call 'em
count the Brady fumble,
which I don't know how that works if you
slap the ball out and then you tackle
the quarterback if that's
considered a sac. Um,
I heard them kind of alluding saying
this was the first sack of the game.
I was at a Superbowl party, which I
usually don't do, but I got a kid now. Um,
and I went actually, you
know, had a good time.
It's a bunch of kids running around,
throwing balls and all that stuff and
I was being the lunatic sitting in the
other room by myself trying to watch
the game or whatever. But, uh, anyways,
you know what's great about having a kid,
uh,
you don't have to watch the halftime show.
Haley,
I want to put her in the
stroller and go for a walk.
So I don't even know
who played the halftime.
I just kept walking by the front door
and I kept hearing music and one of the
music ended. I came back in
and then somebody goes, hey,
great timing, great timing.
It's like, Hey, you know,
I've watched a few of these,
watched a good 40 of them. Um,
anyways,
I've never seen like the defense
was so fucking bad and that game,
it was literally like, how did either
one of these teens even make it here?
I don't know if it was still
weird match up or what. I mean,
I don't know anything about the fucking
eagles considering I thought that
fucking Sproles guy who was still playing,
but I did call it with the running game.
I just didn't know it was that fucking
dude that you got from the dolphins,
whatever. Right. But I knew that that
was going to be a problem. Um, yeah.
I don't know what the fuck
happened to the eagles,
but I will tell you the
New England patriots,
the game this season where I
went like, oh boy, oh Jesus.
We went in at this year was when we played
the Pittsburgh Steelers and we went,
we went down and we scored.
The fucking game was over.
There wasn't enough time
left even with big Ben.
And then we gave up a 90 yard screen pass.
And the only reason why we won that game
was because of that stupid fucking is
it a catch isn't a catch that when he
catches the ball here and he turns and
starts running with the ball,
we don't know if he has possession as he
possesses the ball and reaches over the
fucking goal line.
I,
the my number one thing I want
them to fix in football is,
is that fucking rule. Um, I don't
remember there really being a huge,
is it a catch isn't an a catch controversy
before they fucked with that rule.
So every once in a while,
you know,
you try to make the game
less controversial and you
do dumb shit like that.
Or even the Tuck rule. I mean, that
was fucking stupid. That was a fumble.
It's as stupid as fuck.
He tucked it in. I Dunno,
but I don't know the rule book the
way they do it. It's fucking dumb.
And all you rate a friends
who were jumping up and down
because of patriots fans
said that that was a fumble.
Go watch the fucking roughing the passer
call that you guys got back with old
Kenny stable and Ray Hamilton jumping
in the fucking hear that gave you a God
damn Superbowl.
Okay,
so why don't you take off your fucking a
rocky horror picture show scary rate of
costume and shove it up
your ass. All right. Sorry.
I'm still a little upset that my team
lost tack and fucking Raiders fans who are
about to become the most profitable
fucking franchise in the moderate and NFL
era era of second day go to Las Vegas.
They're going to do so well in Las Vegas.
This is my prediction that I'm going to
say the rams who will eventually move to
Reno or Laughlin Nevada or some shit.
Right.
So anyways,
getting to the game,
that was the ugliest fucking
game collectively of team
defense I've ever seen in
my fucking life. I don't remember
seeing a punter the whole game.
Yeah,
I haven't looked at the stats,
you know, cause my team lost.
So you know you go on
fucking radio silence.
I'm not going on social media cause not
one eagle fan talk to any fucking shit.
And I already looked at my, my feed
last night so it was like a good day.
All this shit.
It's like where was that before the game
when you're green needs were fucking
shaking.
Um,
I think there was two punts,
no sacks other than I guess separating
thing if they count that as a sec.
Okay.
If you told me before the fucking
game started, I'll just say,
cause I don't know what happened.
I'll say the eagles punted once and,
and the fucking patriots punted
once you just told me, all right,
you're not going to sack nick foals once
and the eagles are only gonna punt once
and you'll have one turnover. I'd be like,
oh boy. Oh, this is going to be ugly.
We're going to get the living
shit kicked out of us. And I bet
if you told Eagle, I mean, what the for
the fuck ever the eagles difference.
I thought they were going to
kill us. I was like, Jesus,
this fucking team looks
like those giant teams.
So they've got that great front
before they got to fucking run a game.
They're going to fucking make Brady move.
Okay.
And we're going to be,
we're going to be frustrated and
punting and all of that shit.
And then they're going to have the running
game chewing up the fucking clock. Um,
it was still a great game.
Uh,
and I know there's a bunch of Patriot
fans whining about that trick play. Who,
by the way, Chris Collins worth just
couldn't get over that play going.
They kept going back to it. This guy,
I mean I'm quite is icon and clay,
so la history. It's like you mean the one
the patriots just ran five minutes ago?
Yeah.
You see that at least five times a
fucking year in the NFL regular season.
It wasn't like this unique trick play
and if you watch college football,
you see it about 40 times a year.
It's just this standard fucking play now
I guess illegal formation as if this,
you need to six guys on the line and the
eagles had five and there was one guy,
a cunt hair back,
so I dunno if you want to say that's
illegal formation. I'll tell you this,
with the defense played
yesterday and they,
if they actually called that the eagles
would have scored on the next fucking
play. All right. That'd be one thing.
If we were actually stopping them,
I would actually look at that and be like,
well wait a minute, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. You know, my buddy said
something funny. He goes, you know what,
the Patriot scored on that
and we actually won the game.
They would be calling it a formation
gate for the next three fucking years,
which is hilarious. We probably would've
lost a draft pick because of that plate,
but there's no fucking way,
um,
on any level I would ever take
that victory away from the eagles.
They, they total level, they
won the fucking Cape. All right.
And Ah,
this is how bad the difference was.
Even on the last play of the fucking game,
they still had to give the eagles fan
base a fucking heart attack when they
batted the ball all around me.
They like,
it was like three patriots that had a
shot at the balls as it was like hanging
in the air. Um, just a really a weird,
weird fucking game. But,
um, I can't say this,
I am really happy for,
uh,
for eagles fans and the
city of Philadelphia and I
know that I will always be
sort of connected to that city as if I
fucking hate them. I don't, I never did.
It was just,
I had a bad show.
I was in Philly and I went after this
shit that you loved. But I, I really,
the only time I ever really hated a
Philadelphia team was when the Celtics and
sixers had that great rivalry. But
other than that, you know what I mean?
We're in the AFC. You're in the
NFC. We were in the Adams Division.
You are in the Patrick's division.
I actually used to like
the flyers back in the 80s,
because I liked fights and
I remember rooting for them.
I think they played Edmonton,
I forget who they played,
but they were going to lose the game.
And I didn't know where Ron Hextall had
an absolute shit fit and for whatever,
I've never seen a goalie
do this. Just skated out of the
crease and started fighting.
Somebody just completely spazzed out,
can ran out, skated out, I should say. Um,
but after a while,
I couldn't become a flyer.
I couldn't stay a flyers fan because
they reminded me of how I was living my
life where it's like, well, this worked
fucking 30 years ago. Let me, uh,
let me keep trying it every year.
You know,
when they kept trying to beat their way
to the cop cars at one because that one,
I'm a cup at 74,
75 and then they continued to do
it well into the two thousands.
Um, so anyways, what else? I
made a couple of notes here.
Uh, I think that was
it. I think that was it.
Um, anyways, but this one,
it doesn't hurt the way
those giants one's heart. Um,
this one is just a, this one
just kind of sucks, but anyways,
congratulations.
That's fucking great.
So now the Philadelphia Eagles and
the last 10 years, the Philadelphia,
the city of Philadelphia has won a
world series and they won a Superbowl.
So now they need the flyers.
It's 76 is to win,
which I don't know how the
fuck that's going to happen.
So, uh, anyway, stay. You Go,
there's my Superbowl chatter.
Once again,
congratulations to the eagles fans and uh,
you know,
patriots, feds, he has his, here's the
positive that you can take from it.
All right. The team come
100% over achieved this year.
All right.
Not Having an Edelman the whole year,
haven't Gronk concussed and Brandon
hooks, cooks, I should say hooks.
Brandon cooks essentially
knocking himself out of the game.
I've never seen anybody do something
like that. When he peeled back,
I literally yelled,
what the fuck is he doing?
I'd never seen a guy peel back with the
ball and be looking the wrong way and
get himself knocked out of the game.
They should have been like
Benny Hill music playing.
I don't know what the f I think he
was so surprised he was that open.
He didn't know what to do with.
He was like,
he had his own public park to himself.
Um,
anyways, he, here's, here's your, uh, as
patriots fans, how you can get past this.
Um, just be happy. You know, every, every
time the Patriots win the Super Bowl,
you know, when you really
think about it, you don't,
have you ever gotten a ring yourself?
You don't get a ring.
All you have to do is now go out and
buy a championship tee shirt and get a
subscription to sports illustrated.
So it's nice, you know,
to avoid that expense. Um, anyways,
so there you go.
And now the worst feeling ever,
almost as bad as you team losing
the fucking super bowl is a,
the football season is officially over.
No College,
no pro, no Canadian, no nothing.
MMM,
whatever.
You got March madness coming up.
Formula One starts next month or whatever.
But um,
anyways, congratulations to the
Patriots on a great season. And, uh,
once again, congratulations to the
DC, you're super bowl champion,
Philadelphia fucking eagles, man.
Who would have ever thought, um,
now wait a minute, let's go
around the league. So who's left?
We all know the Cleveland browns
and they certainly didn't take a
step towards what he won this year,
but you never know enough. Sure.
They got a bunch of draft picks.
Let's go run a league. Patriots
obviously have one giant is obviously,
if one jets won Superbowl three eagles,
if one Pittsburghers one ravens have one,
Washington is one.
The Carolina Panthers,
Owen too.
Uh,
Tennessee titans
lost to the rams and one of the great
super bowls of all time. All right.
They never want to see Houston Oilers.
They did want an AFL title,
I believe the first year.
Okay.
Jacksonville Jaguars never
won. So there's, there's
three teams set up. Never won.
MMM.
And the brown sets for.
Okay.
Bangles. Never one. That's five
lions. Never one. That's six.
Dolphins have one. Tampa
Bay's one. Atlanta never one.
That's seven. I'll shut this.
Whole lot of teams left.
Okay.
New Orleans is one. Okay. Right.
Moving on up. And then as
soda never won. Bears have won
Kansas City chiefs one. So go for
cowboys. Have one. Houston Texans.
If never one.
That's nine Broncos have one.
Arizona cardinals. Never one. That's 10.
Okay.
San Diego Challenges.
Never one. Jesus Christ.
This is really saying about how
many dynasties has been in football.
The rams never won.
Fuck yeah.
Raiders of one 49 is if
one Seattle have one,
I probably missed a team or two there.
So 12 teams haven't won it.
Okay.
20 teams have.
Okay,
well I guess you know something.
If, when the Patriots,
we say the Steelers have
one six pages of one five,
okay.
49 is one five and cowboys have
one five that's 21 of the 52 bowls.
Right. They're spread out against
what's just for fucking teams.
Giants got four.
So that's 24.
Yeah,
packers have four,
that's 28.
So it's one for like six
teams of one 28 of them. Well,
I guess it kind of makes sense then.
So I guess since there's really
no shame at this point, you know,
having never won a fucking Superbowl and
considering like a lot of those teams I
mentioned, we're expansion teams like
the panthers, Texans and fucking Jaguars.
Um, all right, there you go.
Another goddamn season out the window
and I have to be honest with you. Uh,
okay.
I am really fearful.
You know what Tom Brady going to be
turning 41 here that it might be a long,
long time before we ever
get back to another one. Uh,
if we don't get back next year
because, uh, I'll never forget,
you know,
everybody talks about Dan Marino who a
on undeservingly gets all this shit for
having never won a Superbowl. I mean,
the game had passed his coach by,
he never had a running game. He
never had a defense. He still did.
What he did was he supposed to tackle
people too and come up with the fucking
game plan.
The man would literally throw per 6,000
yards of season if the rules of pass
coverage where the way
they, they are. All right.
Now that guy went to a super bowl in
his second year, I believe in 1984.
Not only did the dolphins never
get back during his career,
Dave never been back period since then.
So that was 34 fucking years ago.
Dan Marino was 23 years old.
He's now 57.
Yeah,
that's how fucking nuts this is.
So I'm telling you right now
when Brady and Belichick leave,
mmm.
You know,
I'm going to be 50 years old.
If we go through what the dolphins
go through, I will be 84 years old.
Still waiting for them to get back.
So I don't take any of this for granted
because there's a lot of patriot.
People hate the pages go. I mean, you
guys, you must study big shining anymore.
It's like, no dude, it's
fucking unbelievable.
I'm trying to enjoy every second
of it cause I always think, okay,
this is the last time we're getting back.
Okay,
thank God we want, this is the last
time we getting back off. Fuck, we lost.
Okay.
This is the last time. Oh, we lost
again. All we won. We won again.
Now we've fucking la. Yeah, I
dunno. I Dunno. It's fucking, uh,
you know when for all your Patriot
haters, I'll tell you, I mean, you're,
you're really supple birds.
He said it best. He goes,
it's like you're literally watching
something you'd be probably never going to
fucking see again that level of dominance.
But, um, I do understand it. You know,
if you love you fucking team and all
that shit. But, uh, anyways, I, uh,
we had deaf and I don't know
where we are in the run.
We're definitely in the final 10% of it.
And I don't know if that was
the last time, but we shall see.
We shall definitely see. But
you know, here's the thing.
I think if they never get back again
in 34 years, so they do. Either way,
I'll be sitting there
watching because I have not.
Um, okay. What is that?
20 minutes in? All right, let's read
a little bit of fucking advertising.
Shao we shall. We are
right. And don't, don't
talk about how every man looks
better in a suit. I'll tell ya,
I don't think I've ever been. So star
struck is when I see Tom Brady in a suit.
You know what I mean?
Hair and just all the perfect places are,
Indochino is the largest
custom apparel company.
They make suits and shirts made to your
exact measurements for a great fit. Yeah.
So after getting measured,
stop fucking eating stupid.
I'll try to remember exactly what you ate.
Guys love the wide selection of high
quality fabrics and the options to
personalize all the details, including
the lapel jacket lining, Eagles fans.
You can get Superbowl
champions, right? You're a,
you're a little lapel monogram and
much more. Here's how it works.
Pick your fabric, choose your
customization, submit your measurements,
place your order and wait for it
to arrive in three weeks or less.
You can shop online and indochino.com
or visit any of their showrooms across
North America this week.
My listeners can get any premium
premium Indochino suit for just 359
dollars@indochino.com that's I n d o,
c h,
I n O,
a indochino.com when
entering burr at checkout,
that's over 50% off the regular price
for premium made to measure suit plus
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com promo code burr
for any premium suit for just $359 plus
free shipping and credible deal free,
perfectly tailored suit. All right,
and is the latest, Oh, here's
the latest advertiser I got high.
Uh, you'd never turned us the word
you hate the most when you're married.
You'd never turned down the free money,
right in debit turned down free money,
right? That's how you read it. Well,
if you shop online without the best cut
coupons, you're already paying too much.
Coupons is this for like old people,
old people online.
We'll be back after these messages.
Fortunately,
there's a free browser extension called
honey that automatically finds the best
coupons on the web. So you always get
the best prices on everything online.
Please personalize this
to make it your own. Okay?
In two clicks,
oh wait,
let me make this my own in two
fucking clicks ad Oh Connie,
to add height,
any bot browser for free.
Then shop like you normally do.
Honey Scans and tests.
Millions of coupons in
the background at checkout
will automatically apply the best
coupon to get you the biggest discount.
Over 7 million fucking people use Aha
Annie e every day and together they've
saved millions of dollar when hi honey,
he's got your back. You'll never
overpay for anything ever again.
Mandatory personal endorsement.
What's the last purchase you made
with honey? How much did you save?
I don't know how to use it.
I'm fucking 49 years old.
I'll have to figure out how to use this.
Uh,
there's no reason to add honey to your
browser today. I'll tell you right now.
If I use tawny,
you know what I would use it for to buy
a New England patriots AFC championship
tee shirt.
Oh,
making a joke about your own team.
There's no reason to add honey
to your browser today. It's free.
Takes just seconds to install
and will save you tons of money.
Add honey to your browser
for free right now.
To now join@honey.com h o n e y.com/burr
that's joined honey.com/ [inaudible]
okay.
Hey, all right. Dollar
Shave club, everybody.
Dollar Shave Club,
everyone knows dollar shave club ships.
Amazing raises for a few bucks.
What you might not know is that dollar
shave club also has products for pretty
much everything else you need in the
bathroom. Bodywash, Shampoo, Hair Gel,
lip balm, everything. If you're
sick of the nonsense at the store,
now's the time to try out dollar
shave club for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away their shit. Shower,
shave starter kit, start a set, sorry. Uh,
to new members for only $5.
This starter said feature
features their executive razor.
And three trial size versions of their
most popular products that help you stay
fresh,
so fresh and so clean.
And your first box you will
receive the shave butter honey
bodywash and one white
Chari oh button wipes.
You will receive their executive razor,
which includes their premium weighty
handle and full cassette of chart
cartridges.
And after the first box replacement
cartridges are sent for only a few bucks a
month.
This offer is exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com
slash burr that's dollar
shave club.com/burr dollar shave
club's high quality products.
We'll have new cupboard from
face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There is no better time to try the
club and lastly, but not leastly.
Okay.
stamps.com
okay.
Postage rates have gone up again,
let stamps.com keep your rates down with
postage discounts up to 40% discounts
you can't even get at the post office.
stamps.com gives you 3 cents
on every letter you send.
Pay 200 2016 prices for 2018 stamps.
Just use stamps.com to automatically
calculate and print the correct amount of
postage for every letter or package
you sent. Sam Saab chrom makes it easy.
They'll send you a digital scale to
automatically calculate the exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of mail based on your needs.
Anything you can do
with@thepostofficeyoucandorightfromyourdeskwithstampsdotcomiusestamps.com
anytime I'm sending out my posters
when I'm on the road, right?
I'm a moron if I could figure out,
so can you,
and right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com Cisa can't. So I
got the Invisalign in. Sorry people,
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the homepage and type in
bird. That's stamps.com enter
Burren look who Jess came in.
The one thing that can put my smile
on my face after a super bowl.
Bloss my wife and my beautiful daughter.
She insisted on coming in here.
Okay, come on in. You know what?
I don't know what happened last yesterday
and that Superbowl. I can't explain.
They should've been Benny Hill
music playing during that game.
Can you give us your breakdown,
honey bunch. What happened?
Pushing the microphone away. You don't
even want to talk about you so devastated.
That's cause you're spoiled
because this is, hi. Hi.
Hi.
The Patriots won the Super Bowl every
year of your life until this year.
That's all right. She's one years old.
They've already been there twice. Oh,
it all she knew was winning.
Sorry.
Sorry that you had to learn
this ugly lesson. Oh my God.
If they showed nick foals wife
one more frigging time. I get it.
Is it an unbelievable,
I guess I have to say as a redhead,
the white blonde people get treated.
I swear to God, if she was a Brunette,
maybe they would have panned passed her
face to some fat eagles fan eight and a
cheese steak.
Are you going to say anything?
He just throwing your hands up.
Is it weird that I have headphones
on and a microphone here.
He say Mama, nothing. Nothing.
Nothing. She's speechless after that loss.
Right? There you go. There's the Mama.
Can you say hi? Can you
say hi buddy? You can wave.
Hi. Hey, who played the halftime show
yesterday? Jassen Timberlake. Oh,
it was Justin Timberlake. Oh
Shit. I should have watched that.
I was pushing her up and
down the driveway, having a
grand old time. All right.
Hi.
Okay.
All right, let's stop. Stop
trying to show off here. Let me,
let me finish my podcast here.
All right. Come on. Say Bye. Bye.
David showed a quarterback's wife
that much sense. Um, Kurt Warner's,
you know,
although she was a Brunette,
so there goes that theory. No, right.
They're stupid palm palm hat on. You're
in an indoor stadium. All right, Bill,
don't be a bitter Douche. All right, I
won't. Congratulations to nick foals wife.
Um, I was hoping that the Patriots
were in to kick the shit out of the,
just so I could have seen
this sports headline, you know, and if,
if nick falls through like
three interceptions, they
would've said Nick folded,
but it didn't happen. Um,
all right, Formula One,
let's get to the questions here to see.
Oh No,
am I going to tell you about
my show in Reno? So, uh,
I want to thank everybody
that came out in Reno,
even the dose that tried to interrupt
my show and have a youtube moment. Um,
I, I, I fucking love that city,
man. I had such a great time.
I went up there and I worked
with my buddy Rick Dalea,
who we started out together,
um,
way back in Boston in 1992. I think
he may be started like a month before.
We were trying to figure
out who started before,
but I always remembered seeing him and um,
you know,
seeing a friend, you know,
Jesus Christ and we were, were,
I've known him for 26 years.
I've actually known him longer than the
age we were at when we met each other.
So it was,
you know,
just all the stories were coming
out and when he brought me up,
he actually made a reference to
this fucking hell Gig that we did.
Nick's comedy stop where I started.
Um,
they, I remember that was
such a big deal to work at.
That comedy club was just a legendary
place. It was the house that, you know,
Steve Sweeney and Don Galvin and all
those guys built and we were both,
you know, no name comics,
just pass being open.
Micros had started hosting in like,
you know,
outside rooms like Dick Doroty
rooms and all of that. And um,
Rita from,
Nick's called us up to do a private gig
for Nick's comedy stop and I couldn't
believe it. I was like, oh my God,
things are finally starting to happen.
And you know, mean to Leah found out, you
know, we were working with each other,
which should've been a red flag
right there going like you,
they called you to, oh my God,
they believe in us. Right.
That should have been a fucking red flag
right there because both of us should
have been opening for somebody who
knew what the fuck they were doing.
But instead we show up.
It was to fishermen's faced
in the north end of Boston,
which is the Italian section,
or at least it was back in the day.
I don't know what, what, what goes
on there now. Everything, the prices,
they just driven every, every, any, any
sort of like culture has been removed,
which is why I like
going to be so-called B,
c and d level cities because there's
still that unique vibe there.
Um, you'll go there and see stuff that
you don't see in every other fucking city.
Um, you know, the same 10 fucking
corporate chains in whatever, um,
everybody walking around with their
Instagram look on their face, you know?
Um, so when he was, we show
up to this Gig, it's outside,
literally in the fucking
streets. They tell his story
last week, I can't remember.
And it was like fucking band
on stage when no hits your eye,
like a big pizza pie.
All the Italians is sitting there singing
and you're really just see the field
is great sense of family,
tradition and culture.
And now you've got these two pasty faced,
you know at least Rick was half Italian,
you know,
I'm fucking German Irish just standing
there with my fucking fire engine red
hair.
So deleah goes on,
nobody has any idea what's like
this fucking guy I got now.
They got a little comedy
and people like what the,
what the fuck is this guy talking about?
And then delete it goes on stage
trying to smile through probably
the biggest panic of his life.
And I remember wanting to laugh at him,
but I couldn't because I
knew I had to go on next.
So whatever he was feeling
I was about to feel.
But at least for me it was going to be
worse cause we leased before he went on
stage, he had fucking hope. Like,
well maybe this will be good.
But when I saw reco on stage,
I had confirmation that this
was not going to be good.
I just remember him just fucking
interrupting this great fucking party,
which is so many of the
early standup gigs, you know,
just interrupting something that everyone
was totally enjoying and they really
don't need you.
And then they don't know that you're
coming up there and then you go up there
and they're like,
what the fuck is this?
MMM.
Well,
I remember it was when I went on stage
bombing and just looking up and seeing
all these old Italian ladies
like hanging out the window,
just looking down at us. Like,
like, what, what the fuck is this?
It just afterwards, I forget,
we probably walked out of there.
There's no subway stop or
he walked over to our cars.
MMM.
I don't even remember what, anyway, it
was great to work with him. But, um,
I was in the middle of my set having a
great time and I do this bit where I make
fun of the troops a little bit, you know
what I mean? And it's not even, you know,
it's not even fucking remotely,
it's like a fucking hilarious bit that
the first time I did it, I did it.
At a VFW to make sure that, you
know, the way I was doing it,
I did it in front of the troops.
They were all fucking dying laughing.
I mean those guys say that lost their
legs over there and shit and they was
still laughing. They love the
fucking bit. So I do the bit there,
you know,
and I've moved on from the bid and at
this point I'm making fun of Isis and all
of a sudden this, this guy walks all
the way up from the back of the room.
Unfortunately it,
the chairs were like where he couldn't
get all the way up to the front.
He starts yelling at me,
pointing at the stage,
go show some fucking respect
what he started seeing.
I'm trying to have his fucking
youtube moment, you know what I mean?
And I was like,
what?
Show some respect for what he's still in
one of those fucking things like that.
Yeah.
I love other military is just so fucking
off limits now who supports the troops
or you just have to constantly be blowing
the fucking military that she can't
even make fun of somebody in the Navy
who all he does is swab the fucking decks
and it's getting a standing ovation
walking through the fucking airport.
I've done that fucking pit.
It's in front of so many troops.
They've all funded funding this fucker.
You know this fat fuck.
Oh my God,
I went off on that guy show.
So why don't you show some fucking
respect and lose some weight?
You fat cunt for your fellow American
for every time you get the middle seat on
a flight and you fat fucking
mantat spill into the other.
I'm so fucking sick.
I'm so fucking sick of everybody being
so God damn fucking offended at comedy
shows and just making the
whole moment about themselves.
You fucking mouth breathing chimp,
Jesus fucking Christ.
If you can't fucking see through
the fucking whatever that fucking
expressionists see the forest through
the fucking trees with all of this shit.
I just can't fucking help you.
And considering all the shit that
I had said up until that point,
I didn't show any remote respect
for anything. Every fucking subject.
That's what kills me.
I blamed women for sexual harassment.
That's how I started my fucking show.
Where it was the risk,
where we're the fuck was he
during that one fat fucking cunt?
Oh my God.
I was so fucking mad at that guy.
I hated that security escorted him out.
I appreciated that they did that
thinking that I want it to it.
I wanted to talk to that guy for
the rest of the fucking show.
Walks all the fuck way up.
You know,
he was waiting for his Oprah round of
applause when I told him to go fuck
himself. Everybody left. I
can't believe that. You know,
that's the classic thing,
like a comedy show that usually
ends up on the fucking Internet. Um,
you know what I mean?
That's self righteous fucking Douche bag.
You know what I mean?
Where everything else that I sent up to
that point was so fucking ridiculous and
absurd. And then that's the
one that you're going to
take fucking seriously. Like,
what kind of a fucking moron.
That's what I'm saying is his case like,
did you really think I'm anti
my own country? You dumb fuck.
And when you guys come out to my
show, when you see the bit, okay,
it's so fucking pedestrian.
It's ridiculous.
And I want to, even though when
I did the fucking bit at the Vfw,
the troops came up to me and said,
can't we say that to each other?
But this fucking guy had to fucking, you
know, take his hair out of his pony tail,
Tassel it around and come. This tab is
big fucking head, Roland moment. Ah,
fucking kill yourself.
I hope you fucking have a heart attack.
If fat fucking cunt. You know what
it was was if he didn't like the bit,
then heckle me. The fact that he came
up there and he's like pointing at me,
yelling at me like he's like,
I'm his kidneys, my fucking dad.
Anyways. Anyways, let me, let me
just fucking that, other than that,
the Gig and Reno was fucking awesome.
Um,
and I got to be telling you that that
was actually more upsetting to me than
watching my team fucking Lusa soup.
Both.
Um, all right. Anyways,
let's get into the questions here for
this week to Formula One. Oh, by the way,
or Billy's getting in. It's continuing
with his getting in fucking great shape,
man. Um, I had made it, my goal is,
you know, turning 50 and Jude, you know,
two years of doing stand up comedy
and trying to get a positive out of a
negative five people showed up.
What do I do here?
Do I give in to the fact that this five
people, oh, do I make those five people,
which they brought another 50. You know
what I mean? You get when you fucking,
I dunno,
when you're in this fucking business,
the greatest thing about this business,
unless you knew somebody
when you got into it,
most people get into it and they don't
know anybody and they have no idea what
to do. Um, and they're standing out
in the street in broad daylight,
in the Italian section of
Boston eating your Red Dick.
I mean, if you, if you don't
figure out a positive mindset, uh,
you're really not going to,
you're not going to fucking,
you're not going to survive.
So I'm turning 50, which, uh,
I used to think was
going to be devastating.
I'm actually really excited to try to get
myself in the best shape I've been in,
in Bob about 20 years. So, um,
I'm trying to get down to my,
uh,
basically the weight I was at when a,
in the shape I was in when I started.
Now I'm obviously going to fall
short because no matter what I do,
I'm still fucking about 30 years older.
But, uh, that's not what it's about.
It's about going for it. And
I'll still, you know, so anyways,
I have a weight that I want to
get into my fucking shoulder.
The rotator cuff feels great.
Um,
and I finally have been able to get a
regimen between all the information that
I've gotten over the last year.
Um,
and I've put together a
program that that is, is,
is really fucking working for me.
And I have to tell you,
you know what I did the other day,
other than taking my beautiful
daughter to the park on the swing,
which I think I'm going to do again today,
it's my favorite thing ever is
she was on the swing and um,
I was able, you know, once, once
they got to swing going, cause I'm,
I could finally lift my
right arm over my head.
I have been able to take my
shirt off, um, with both.
I've had to take it out of my left hand.
I mean it'll take my shirt off with,
with both hands in like
over a year and a half,
which is really fucked up my
closing bit. Everybody, you know,
cause I really tried to get
sexy in the end, you know, um,
I was actually able to reach up and
hold onto like the bar above the,
and I made sure I didn't put any
weight on the arm all the way.
It was obviously my feet were still on
the ground and I just gave it a little
bit of a fucking stretch. And it was
just this tightness but not pain.
Cause what happens, I found anybody
else going through this shit is,
is when you have an injury like that,
you get into this PR protective,
like, um, the way you hold yourself.
And it's fucking crazy man.
Like having not put my hand
above my head for over a year,
like I can't physically do it anymore
because those tendons don't get stretched
and all this fucking Shit just, I dunno,
grows over it or whatever. They just,
it's weird. It feels, it
doesn't feel like pain.
It's like there's a doorstop
and I just see, or a governor,
I just can't go any further. So, um,
after doing all these other exercises,
I end with that and it feels tremendous.
It was funny,
I was doing that while watching the
Superbowl and one of these others,
patriots fans is laughing at
me like, dude, you're really
getting into this game.
And I was like, no, no, sorry man. I'm
just fucking working out my, uh, shoulder.
Um, so anyways, uh, I hope
that helps anybody out that,
that has set that, that issue. So I
will actually be able to work out.
But the great thing is I've discovered
bands working out with bands,
um, you know, in a door jam and all that,
which is really going
to help me on the road.
And I think I'm done with the
weightlifting for a long time.
That's kind of what got me into this
year's of weightlifting and not doing
enough back exercises.
And the front part of my body was way
stronger than the back and it pulled my
shoulders forward and one of them
came up and then I, you know,
was bench pressing and just the bones,
I don't know that,
that the rotator cuff tendon just rubbed
on it and got inflamed and then I was
just fucked. And it's really
something that if I, if I,
if it ever happens again, I'll be able
to get out of it and like, you know,
six to eight weeks by just didn't
know what to do. I thought, oh,
this will work itself out. And then
they just became all fucking glued up.
So anyways.
Um,
and have you ever gone through anything
just remotely physical like that to
finally just be able to fucking take
your shirt off or brush your teeth?
You know what I mean?
I'll put the shaving cream on my
head when I go to shave my head.
I always had to put it in
the left hand, you know? Uh,
I'm fucking mess. All right, here we go.
Formula One, everybody a, they there.
Billy the red face cut.
I've been a longtime listener for about
10 years now and the podcast has always
been a great break from the
drudgery of everyday life,
especially back in my university, the
university days. Okay. I'm done blowing,
you know. Anyways, my grandfather,
father and I are all car lovers.
That's great.
I remember falling Formula One closely
as a kid when shock villa new and Michael
Schumacher back in
1997.
I'm so pissed I missed that
because everybody tells me
I miss the great days of
Formula One.
Uh,
listening to you get into Formula One
had me thinking of getting back into it
myself.
With that in mind.
I decided to buy myself an early birthday
present and bought tickets for the
Spanish Grand Prix in Barcelona for
this upcoming season for my old man.
And I do, that's the shit I'm
trying to go to two races a year,
so I'm trying to figure
out what I'm going to do.
It's either going to be Mexico City in
Brazil or if I do some tour dates over in
Europe, I'll just book end
them with the race. Uh,
we shall see. Obviously Mexico
City is deceivingly far away from,
uh,
la.
Like I always picture that it's just
south of Los Angeles cause you know,
you just go south and you're in
fucking Tiawana. Let me look that up.
Where the fuck is it? Ah, you know
what? I got ahold of Microphonia can I,
can I do this? Do I have this ability? Uh,
here we go north,
uh,
Merrick,
I see a map.
Here we go. Come on. Come on.
Slow Internet. All right, clicking on it.
Oh yeah,
it's like south of like fucking Houston
or New Mexico or something like that,
right?
Yeah.
All right. Where do we go? There's
Australia with the fuck am I all right?
Zooming in. I really
should've hit pause. Oh yeah.
Mexico City is like south of San Antonio,
so it's like flying all
the way to San Antonio.
It's like basically flying all the way
across and then all the way south again
for almost the same distance is probably,
yeah,
the equivalent of flying to like Tampa
or something like that. But then Brazil,
if I go to Brazil,
I mean that's all the way you always,
I used to think of when New York,
when my buddies just to go to Brazil,
that they were flying due south and the
due south actually would get you into
like Peru or the western
side of South America. Um,
I would love to go down there too.
Um,
yeah,
maybe I'll do that.
And then how that would actually be done
with all the races on this side of the
world. Uh, who knows? That's such
a cool thing that you're doing,
doing that with your dad though.
Anyways, plowing ahead. Um,
I know you liked the Air India team. I
also liked the uh, Williams Martini team.
I just like to colors and I don't want
to pick a perennial powerhouse like
Mercedes or Ferrari.
So my question is,
which team race or did you enjoy watching
most by father and I are going to pick
a team to root for during the upcoming
season to make our father son weekend a
little more fun. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Um,
okay.
Who did I like? I actually, Daniel
Ricardo is probably, you know,
the closest to a Lewis Hamilton and
I would also say I really liked,
uh, uh, cheese.
I'm so new to the sport and I haven't
thought of them that did that guy. Uh, oh,
I know in, in his teammate there,
his teammate was a fucking maniac.
Hold on a second. I've got to make
sure nobody switched on a team.
Let's say red bull.
Okay.
Racing team, that kid who
was like 20 years old, uh,
drivers, here we go and kick my
seat. She should be switched teams.
Max Verstappen was really fun to watch.
Um,
I would say out of the youngest of the
young drivers, he's probably the best.
Um,
I don't know if he's still on the team.
These guys seem to jump around like free
agents and then it's all about getting
on the Ferrari and Mercedes team,
which you know,
two seasons in is getting a little boring.
So I would like to see
somebody else a win, you know,
so, uh, I max for step and I guess
that's, that's what I would say.
I would say that and I'm, I'm,
that's such a great thing to do.
I'd never been to Spain. That's
amazing. I am going to be doing a Gig,
I believe to celebrate my 50th birthday.
I believe it's coming together over
in Europe. Uh, I'm going to go,
I think I might be doing a gig
somewhere in England and then,
uh,
um,
be with my lovely wife and beautiful
daughter and maybe we were going to go to
France again. I'll try to polish
up and some of my French, but I'm,
if there's any races over there,
you know what, you've inspired me.
I want to talk to my, the guy who books
me today and I'll be like, we got,
we got to figure out, you know what
Formula One race is going on over there.
Cause I got add that 50th birthday and
go to a formula one race over in Europe.
Man, that would be sick. All
right. More Formula One shit.
Formula One grid girls.
Hey Billion Wallace and big
fan from Glasgow, Scotland,
uh, Formula One just announced
that they're getting rid
of the grid girls because
they feel this custom does not
resonate with our brand values.
And clearly is it odd with the
modern day social societal norms?
Same thing has happened with the darts
and it's looking likely for boxing and
UFC in the future. Are
these probably, Ugh, Ugh,
these probably ugly feminists
doing nice looking girls
out of a job or are they doing
the right thing? All right.
I don't know what the fuck I kind
of know what you're trying to say.
What are your thoughts? Cheers and
go fuck yourself. You can't, um,
yeah, that's just all,
you know, lip service,
no pun intended. It's just
bullshit. You know what I mean?
And you know,
I think it's all bullshit.
Here's the deal to say, this customer
does not resonate as to say it's clearly,
is it odd with modern day social
norms? It isn't. It's a it.
It's 100% at odds with
with the public horse shit,
political correctness,
which all political correctness really is,
is being phony.
You know what I mean?
It's just it just denying
what you're really feeling,
denying what you really want
to say, denying what you're
really fucking thinking.
That's why comedians seems
so fucking outrageous.
Yeah.
They always say,
Oh,
you're saying the things that
people take but afraid to say it.
They're not afraid to say it.
They say it in their cars.
They say what their friends, they
say it at home. You know I'm not,
I'm not talking about being
a racist fucking moron.
All right.
They're basically trying to say that
men do not enjoy looking at beautiful
women.
Okay.
This is against the societal norm that
people do not gravitate towards beauty,
both male and female. Like,
if you're a good looking guy,
you're not going to have your pick
of the litter when it comes to women.
Okay.
And vice versa.
Like if you're a beautiful woman that's,
you're not going to have to fucking,
you know what I mean? The, I mean, you
could look at it and like a negative way.
I always thought that because
it was outside of this country,
I always thought that they had a better
way of presenting beautiful women.
That it wasn't just like that
Hooters vibe that we have here.
Like does it look to just stick my
dick between those knockers, you know,
the ugly way that we fucking do
everything over here. You know? Um,
I just,
I think what that is is they probably
got enough crap from these women's groups
and they just don't need
the headache. So, um,
and I also feel that a lot of, you
know, when they say the, you know,
you're exploiting women and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I think there's a lot of truth in that.
I don't think it's,
it's that way with this. I
think that's, that's, you know,
what are they doing? What exactly are
they doing? Are they fucking, you know,
twerking and all that shit.
That's just a beautiful woman walking
around with a ring card. That's it.
You know, getting attention in
a very safe fucking way. Me,
what is the fucking problem? You
know? And I do know that, you know,
the way a guys can handle a good looking
guy who's fucking Jack down at the end
of the bar, you know, a better
looking guy. We've booked it.
You pluck a boot know to go fight him.
You know,
women do the same thing with the better
looking woman that comes walking into
the bar. They fucking hate
him. That's, that's it.
So I think it's pretty fucking childish.
However,
Formula One is on ESPN and you know,
ESPN used to be, but now they kind of ruin
everything. So I'm going to blame them.
They are, they are obviously
with too fucking stupid to keep.
Well Buxton, who was, was
phenomenal at his job. Um,
I dunno. So yeah, I think that's all
the whole thing is his fucking dumb.
And eventually there's
going to be a backlash.
God forbid there's a beautiful
woman walking around on
stage God for fucking bid
and guys are like excited by it,
like you know,
in fucking whistle in a little bit.
Who gives a fuck it? Who Cares?
You know what I mean?
This is my problem with feminism is that
all the corrections are made for them,
which is really kind of putting it out
there as if that women don't need to
adjust their fucking behavior in any
ways when it comes to men, you know,
and, and feminists get to speak
in these unbelievable like broad,
no pun intended, blanket fucking
statements, but guys cannot.
You know what I mean? I'll speak in
some blanket fucking terms for men. Hey,
how much you earn your own fucking money.
How about you buy around?
Every once in a while I'll Bowman,
you'd go through a fucking divorce.
She tried to do something fair and try
and instead of trying to take every
fucking last dime you possibly can,
you're greedy cunts are right.
We're moving on to the next one now.
They don't need to adjust that at all.
They don't need to adjust any of
their fucking behavior whatsoever.
They don't do anything wrong whatsoever.
I tell you right now,
if women died that much sooner than men,
you don't think that
there would be a study.
You don't think that there
would be a fucking ribbon.
You don't think some way that they would
blame men on some level that women die
that much earlier than, than, than men.
If it was that fucking way, I dunno.
I think that that's why guys are so funny.
It's because nobody gives a shit about us.
They really don't.
You know what I mean? They didn't, they
just dump anything that happens to a guy.
He's a dude. Yeah. About Solid Zola.
Hate to bear such to be him. Right.
That's it. That's the level of support
we have for one another. Um, all right.
Deported father. Dear Billy Justice. Uh,
two and a half years ago,
my father was deported to Mexico.
He had been in the u s
since 1978 since he was 13.
My family struggled without him
financially and emotionally.
It's been very rough. I must have been
brutal. He's healthy and not dead,
but he can't be with us. Yeah. That's
got to be, oh man, that's fucking brutal.
It's been very frustrating and
words can't describe it. Uh,
I'm getting married in a few weeks and
he wasn't able to be at the wedding every
day. I see people criticized Trump and
can agree with their reasons for doing so.
But my father was deported under Obama.
My family knows three other people
who are also deported under Obama.
My white friends think they're good
people because they liked Obama but never
looked to see what was happening.
Um, they didn't care then they care.
Now it makes me feel very mad
because it feels insincere and lazy.
As a white man who seems fairly
progressive, can you tell me why this is?
What would you suggest? I say to
them, it's an emotional thing for me.
So it's hard to choose the right words.
Congrats on your child.
I have two nieces and it's really the
greatest thing to watch them grow. Uh,
thank you. Um, what can you say to them?
How it depends on how
open minded they are.
People who are really into politics,
which means they 100% watch CNN or
Fox News all fucking day as if they're
getting some sort of fair
and unbiased newsfeed.
You really can't say anything to
either one of them. Um, but I mean,
there are a lot like sports
fans where, uh, I try to see,
you know,
I tried to the best I can to see boats.
Like I could legitimately be happy
for eagles fans. You know what I mean?
I can legitimately look at
fucking Derek Jeter and say,
that guy's fucking great and I can set
aside my hatred of the Yankees are my
wanting for my team to beat
the eagles yesterday. But,
um, you know, it took me
a long time to get there.
Um, so I dunno, I mean,
no one, the way I was wired, I would
just walk right up to him. Bj, you know,
just so you know, you're fucking
angel there. Obama, you know,
who for some reason gets
no shit whatsoever. I mean,
it probably doesn't hurt that he went,
that his presidency was between
two of the fucking right.
Two of the biggest fucking dip shits
I've ever seen is fucking, did I say dip?
Shyman so that cause trying to think all
the fucking word I could sing and not
be too fucking offensive and think that
I'm a fucking lefty here. 100%. Which,
you know, most of the times I am,
but I mean, yeah, he keep food.
We Shantay ain't fucking me. Hey, you're
not getting full weekend when, after that.
And then this guy who
fucking tweets all the time.
And then before that you had a guy shoving
cigars in his fucking people's twats.
I mean,
yeah,
I'll tell,
you know,
it's been really rough since the first
George Bush who actually had the,
you know,
okay,
well we, we, we pushed
Saddam out of Kuwait,
didn't go into fucking Iraq and was,
was strong enough to push back against
the fucking corporation. Say, hey look,
this is not what we were doing over here.
We accomplished our mission and we're
going home. That's it. You know?
So it's been a long fucking time.
So I think that there's a, uh,
yeah,
there's the thing with Obama, at least he
wasn't Bush or Trump, uh, kind of thing,
so that people have a
hard time seeing them.
And I think he gets handled with kids
gloves in the media, you know what I mean?
They, they, you know, every image of him,
he's like kayaking or fucking playing
highlight and all of this shit.
Like the joke I was doing in my
acting like it looks like an erectile
dysfunction ad and they're
really kind of ignoring that,
that guy for all the hope
that he said and everything.
And I know that that job is,
you know, well, I don't know,
like literally no, but I understand
that it's an incredibly difficult job.
And they always say, if you could
get one thing done, which he did,
he did get Obamacare through.
So I guess it was,
uh, an achievement.
But I have to tell you,
as someone who does lean left to watch
him go on tour now with $70 million a
tour dates to go talk to a bunch of
fucking bankers and corporations,
you know, and all of that
and, and just, I dunno it just
as far as the way I read that,
that's just those corporations
washing their bribe money.
Like we got you in office,
you did what we wanted you to do.
Now come talk to us for an hour and
we'll give you a nice six figure paycheck
and we'll all do it. And then you can
be worth over a hundred million dollars.
Like the Clintons, like the bushes
and all, like it's so fucked up,
but none of them get called out on that.
It's like the bushes, the Clintons,
the Obamas.
It's like you guys dedicated your life
to public service and the presidency is
the highest paying job, which now is
like a half a million dollars a year.
If you do two terms,
you're going to grow stops.
You Go, what is that? 500 times
fucking eight, what does that,
that's 4 million bucks.
And somehow they all,
they're,
they're buying giant houses and they
all end up being worth nine figures.
Um, and everybody just looks
the other fucking way. I Dunno.
So, uh, I maybe,
maybe there's someone within your group
that is understanding enough and can see
both sides of that.
You know,
like if I said what I just said about
Obama to a Trump person, they will be
maybe be going fucking bananas.
But then if I even remotely suggested
that Trump seemed a little emotionally
unstable and that it's really doing the
country a disservice to be tweeting in
arguing with people on social
media like a seventh grade girl.
I don't even fucking respond to
people on Twitter when it comes.
Occasionally I do. But this is supposed
to be the leader of the free world,
trying to get a Trump supporter to admit
to how pathetic and embarrassing that
is. I mean, that's just kind of
the world that we're in right now,
but maybe one of those Obama
supporters. Maybe you could, um,
you know, I dunno, but then also
we live in such a fucked up world.
I'm going to believe that you're actually
Mexican and you wrote this and that
you're not some white person that wrote
this shit because they hate Obama.
I have no fucking idea. You never
know. There's no way for me to vet.
So, um, if what you just said
was true, uh, that is horrific.
And I understand what you're saying,
uh,
about Obama because, you know, I,
I think the best thing he had was he
could deliver a speech better than Bush or
Trump, but a, at the end of the
day, I even know the, you know,
the needle kind of lean more left when
he was an office that the ship stayed on
course, if you know what I'm saying. Um,
now what I'm wearing right now,
I want that guy from Reno to come
walking into my fucking broom here.
Heck shows in respect. All
right. Boyfriend's best friend,
a dear Billy boy lady here.
Oh,
here comes some red shoe diaries.
Shit,
I been seeing slash dating my best friend
for almost a year now. And we love
listening to your podcast together.
It's almost, it's absolutely, it's
going absolutely fucking wonderful.
Except the one thing.
Oh,
this is the winter in a
completely different direction.
I thought you would say you wanted to
bang your fucking boyfriend's best friend.
All right. Okay. Um,
it's going absolutely fucking wonderful
except for one thing is best friends
since and pictures of naked slash slash
half naked girls from Instagram to him.
Uh,
we recently became long distance,
so I'm not sure of the frequency still,
but before I moved away,
he did it almost daily.
My issue is one,
his best friend girlfriends complained
to me about it instead of taking it up
with him.
Okay.
And I tell him, I tell her to just
talk to him. Wait, wait, wait.
I don't think there's too
many fucking pronouns in here.
I don't know who the fuck
you talking about. Oh,
his best friend's girlfriend.
So the girlfriend of the guy sending
the pictures complains to me about it
instead of taking it up with him
and I tell her to just talk to him.
And number two,
it's actually hard to take that advice
because I don't want him to think I'm
trying to control his life.
Some of these pictures are actually girls
that they know and not just pictures
from the chive or the code of man.
I don't even know what that is.
My question is,
do I have the right to be heard
about out about this? Well,
are you heard about this?
Yes. I'm going to say yes.
Are you a free person? Yes. As much as
they'll let you be. So I would say, yes,
you do. If so, how do I
bring this up to them?
I've lost over 30 pounds over the course
of us seeing one another and frankly
thought it, it would stop, but it hasn't.
That's not why I lost the weight,
by the way. Did it for myself.
Okay, well that was weird. The,
I thought all of a sudden you were
stressing out or thanks for the advice and
kind of like go fuck yourself. Ah,
well that's great. First of all,
you got yourself in great shape.
You know he's giving you a
standing ovation right now. You're,
you're fucking vitals.
All your major organs are loving you as
we live in a world now where everybody's
a hero, including overweight
people. You know what I mean?
I'm telling you right now, uh, if your
vitals were standing in an airport,
you got off a plane that they would
not be giving you a fucking round of
applause.
Um,
staying in shape is the greatest fucking
thing you could ever do for yourself
and you fucking deserve it.
All right?
And fucking stop playing the victim and
do something about it and admit to the
fact that you're the one with the hand
shoving that fucking cupcake down your
fucking throat. I'm sorry, I'm
getting off track here. Um,
I would actually, I absolutely bring it
up with them. That's completely fucked up.
If that bothers you, you should
say something and that, um,
that other guy,
the guy sending the
photos is being completely
disrespectful to you and you and
your boyfriend. You know,
he's happy in a relationship.
Why the fuck is he doing this shit?
Maybe he's jealous. Maybe he's a moron.
I have no idea.
I would absolutely bring it up to them
and just say it the way he said it. Like,
you know, this is something that's
bothered me for a long time.
MMM.
You know, this is so weird. I actually
think if you don't get emotional,
do you don't like cry
and do the woman thing,
which literally freaks most guys out.
Or maybe I'm superimposing most guys
with the way I feel like when a woman
starts crying, I just started thinking
like, oh Jesus Christ, here we go.
Here's and isn't a high now how do I,
how do I argue my side now when you,
when you as an adult are actually
crying about this right now.
MMM.
Then I'm a pushover. Okay. Cause anytime
my daughter cries, that's it. I'm done.
And my wife just rolls, rolls arise
in me just like she's not even crying.
She's whining bill. And I'm like, I nine
one of them. Fuck am I supposed to do?
MMM.
I would just matter of factly just selling
you. That really hurts me. And, um,
but I didn't want to bring it up to,
cause I didn't want to seem like a Nag,
but I'm just letting you know that that
really bothers me and I don't think it's
right.
And just imagine
if we turn the tables and
one of my girlfriends was
sending me pictures of guys
with their dicks out every day.
Like how would that make you feel?
Okay.
I'm not saying you have to stop doing it.
I'm just telling you that it bothers me.
Just put it on that and let him make the
fucking decision rather than comment.
Cause I can say it.
Tell you as a typical fucking guy,
if you come out,
I believe
talk to you.
All the guys thinking it was like,
oh my God, Oh my God, how the fuck.
I mean I understand that
women are more emotional,
but when you fucking do that in a lot
of ways it's not fair to the guy because
there's no way you can argue with another
adult that is literally breaking down
crying.
Okay.
Okay. I've been in relationships
and I've seen women crying,
you know, talking to me, me about
something to this level crying.
And I'm thinking in my head like,
I haven't seen people crying
like this at a funeral.
So it really takes away your ability
to argue your side if you have a side.
And that causes resentment,
you know, to mention the fact that
women can cry on cue. I swear to God,
I feel like some of the time it's
a minimal manipulation tactics,
but if you are able to just
just say it and just say,
I don't want to be a Nag. And I'm not
saying that he has to stop doing it,
I'm just letting you know
that it really bothers me.
And then if it was going the other way
and I was getting Dick pics sent to me
every day, uh, I don't think
that you'd be too thrilled.
And then just let them deal with that.
And that'd be like,
I'm not gonna say anything else about
it. I'm just letting you know. All right.
And then let him fucking deal
with it and see what he does.
That would be my advice. All right.
Girlfriend has higher sex drive than me.
Um, all right, dear Billy. Fuck nuts.
That reminds me of that
classic Louis C K joke.
Tamil at that time when he was dating
the NYMPHOMANIAC and she and she kept
going, let's do it again.
Let's do it again. And it goes,
and she was really just backing into me
and it really fucking hurt and I wanted
to say,
Hey,
can you stop banging back into me
before your rip my Dick off you fucking
psycho. But instead I
said, hey, take it easy.
All right, girlfriend has higher sex drive
to me. All right, dear Billy. Fuck nuts.
I started dating an old girlfriend from
high school after 10 years of being
apart. Oh, like little when
Harry met Sally. Right.
I'm now 26 and she's 27. We've been
going steady for about seven months.
I love it.
You said we're going steady.
This guy's like an old soul and
everything has been great up until around
Christmas where the problem began.
To give you some background,
I work from seven in the morning.
Uh,
she doesn't go to work until five in
the afternoon and gets out at one.
Oh,
you go to work at seven in the morning.
You didn't tell me when you stopped
though. Um, she doesn't drive,
so I have to pick her up every night.
The only day we have off
together is every other Saturday.
By the time we get back to my place,
I'm completely exhausted and pretty much
falling asleep while she's wide awake
and usually wants to have sex. Recently
my sex drive has plummeted. Yeah,
but you're not getting any sleep.
It's gonna and I can tell
you that having a kid now,
and that's totally true to
sex in your relationship.
It just takes such a back seat. It
kid goes to sleep and it's like, hey,
we could hook up or we could
get like 50 minutes of sleep
point. It's like gold. Um, anyways, um,
recently my sex drive is plummeted.
Not because I don't find her attractive
or because I don't care about her,
but I'm just drained of energy after
working 50 hours a week with maybe four
hours of sleep every night.
And after about five months
of sex every other night,
it starts to feel like a chore. Sometimes.
I've been turning her down lately. Uh,
this has caused a lot of arguments
and fights in the past two months.
That's probably because she
doesn't know why. You know,
guys, you know, generally speaking,
our horn dogs in any, you know,
you could be in the middle of the fucking
having chemo and the in your girl be,
hey, you all, you fucking do
it. You know, banging her.
Will you stand up with that
fucking drip in your arm? Um,
I feel like she doesn't respect my desire
to get some rest and I've suggested
sex in the morning, but at that
point she's already pissed at me.
All right,
well if you communicated it
and
she's still not willing to work with you,
then she's kind of being immature. Yeah.
Uh,
she seems to think I don't care about
her and that when I try to suggest maybe
sex a certain amount a week,
like three or four,
she gets mad at me and that she
always wants tasks to initiate it.
Uh, I've been trying to be more consistent
with being sexually available and more
affectionate lately.
Like visiting her on lunch break and
getting her small clips like flowers to
show that I care. But the
problem is still here. Yeah.
Cause this is all you're
not communicating.
Okay.
Uh,
when we do actually have sex,
sometimes it's just boring for me because
I'm not in the mood or I really don't
have the energy to do
anything but lay there.
I really love this girl and don't want
to lose her due to something like this.
Do you have any advice for my problem
and when we, when we come back,
you bald ginger ball bag.
Um, I would say this,
you guys need to sit down
and have a talk and just say,
just say everything you just said to me.
This is the problem with
most relationships is people
in it say the things that
they should be saying to each other to
other people and then they expect the
other person to be a mind reader.
She has no idea that you
know how tired you are.
Just tell her and just tell her that
you love her and that you're afraid that
you're, that you're going to lose her and
all of that type of stuff. And just say,
the reason why I'm doing it not
been in the mood is not because you,
it's because I'm fucking exhausted.
I'm like a Zombie.
I'm getting four hours of sleep and um,
and just tell her that it hurts you,
that you're hurting her.
So I really needed to clear the air and
just sit down and clear the fucking air.
All right? That's what the fuck I
would do. Okay. That's the podcast.
Once again, congratulations
to you or super bowl champion,
Philadelphia Eagles. Um,
like I said, you know,
I hope you guys know all
the, all these, you know,
I had one bad fucking show in Philly
and everybody thinks I hate the fucking
city.
I actually loved the city.
Other than the fact you have 58 one ways
going to the left before there's one go
into the right
and then another 58 going left and
then 60 going right after that.
It makes no fucking sense. Other than
that, I really don't have a beef with you.
Um, and a lot of times, you know,
I wish that show happened in North
Carolina because I would've just stood on
stage making fun of them for
losing the civil war and a,
the fucking Charlotte
bobcat's in a hornets at all.
I would just make fun of all that,
losing their fucking team and all of that.
That's what I would've done. I just happen
to be, I was actually in New Jersey.
That's the funny thing about all of
it. Um, all right. That's the podcast.
Go fuck yourselves. Um, I
will check in on you on a,
what is it? Thursday. All right. See you.